[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: Hi.
Today, I'm here to tell you all
about Google Cloud's Transfer
Appliance, an easy, secure, and
performant way to physically
ship your data to the cloud.
Transfer Appliance was
created for customers
needing to transfer
large amounts of data
to Google Cloud.
Large-scale data transfers
done over the wire
require network connections
with sufficient bandwidth.
And some customers aren't
able to procure or dedicate
that kind of bandwidth
without disrupting
their critical
business operations.
When an online data transfer
isn't feasible, preferable,
or efficient, the
Transfer Appliance
is the best way to make
a large data transfer.
But how does it work?
We ship you an appliance.
You upload your data.
You ship the appliance back
to a Google upload facility.
And voila, your data is
available in Google Cloud.
The appliance itself is
about the size of a suitcase,
and is easy to move
exactly where you need it.
And Transfer Appliance comes
in two capacities, 40 terabytes
and 300 terabytes.
And any time we're talking about
moving large amounts of data,
security is the
number-one priority.
This device is tamper-resistant
and sealed during shipment,
and is designed to
protect your data.
Transfer Appliance was designed
so that everything you need
is on board the device itself.
When preparing to upload
your data to the appliance,
you'll connect it
to your network.
The on-device display and
included setup guide will
walk you through the process.
To start, power on the device.
Configure for your network.
Begin capturing data.
Once your transfer is
complete, the device
is ready to ship back to
a Google upload facility.
And for customers
who prefer to place
inside a data-center rack, we
have a rackable form factor
available that can
be placed on a shelf.
Once we receive it,
we upload the data
into your Cloud Storage
bucket, then wipe the appliance
when we're done.
Your data is now
available in Google Cloud.
Now you can take advantage
of our powerful analytics
or machine-learning tools,
or simply back up your data
in case you need it later.
Transfer Appliance is
a great fit for data
collection from researchers,
vendors, or other sites
to Google Cloud.
Data replication.
Take advantage of
hybrid architectures
and keep your on-prem
infrastructure
while also experimenting with
the powerful data-analysis
tools Google offers.
Data migration.
Move large amounts
of existing data
to ultra-low-cost
archival storage.
To see if the Transfer
Appliance is right for you,
check out cloud.google.com.